we begin with a very serious story a
Delaware woman who says that she was
severely beaten at a resort is telling
her story in public for the first time
we want to warn you that these pictures
may be disturbing not maybe disturbing
these pictures are very disturbing
Tammy Lorenz daily says in January that
she was attacked by a stranger inside
the resort where she was staying in the
Dominican Republic CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson has
reported on travel safety for months
Dana when I saw these pictures this
morning honestly it was stomach-turning
to me what have you learned absolutely
horrifying I learned that it's too
common and that is the problem more than
eighty percent of women who travel alone
for work say they've had at least one
safety related concern in February we
spoke to a woman who was sexually
assaulted by a stranger who tricked the
front desk into giving him her room key
so whether it's for work or vacation the
women we spoke to are urging others to
stay vigilant it's very difficult very
difficult reliving Tammy Lawrence daily
was on vacation with her husband at the
majestic elegance resort in the
Dominican Republic when she says she
went downstairs alone one night in
search of a snack I could hear footfalls
behind me and before I could turn around
he plowed into the back of me Tammy says
the man was wearing a resort uniform she
tried to fight him off but he strangled
her and she lost consciousness when I
came to it was to him beating me about
the head kicking me and beating me it
was hours before people at the resort
found her in an underground crawl space
she was brought to the hospital with
severe facial injuries after months of
physical and emotional recovery she says
she is finally sharing her story as a
warning to others you just have a
feeling of safety and a feeling of you
know paradise but this can happen and it
has happened and it will happen again by
show of hands have any of you felt
uncomfortable unsafe while traveling yes
yes
have any of you had an issue with safety
while traveling yes yes we recently sat
down with Jen Ruiz Jeanne Marie Campbell
and Anaya Richards
who are all frequent solo travelers for
pleasure and work I've had times where I
put something up against the door just
so I would feel comfortable going to
sleep at night in a hotel and it's not
just at hotels and resorts
I personally was attacked by an uber
driver on the way to the airport in
Argentina Jen Ruiz says while on
vacation in Argentina her driver pulled
over on the side of the road forced
himself on her and kissed her she never
reported it me I really just I had a
sense of shame associated with it where
I blamed myself Tammy says she blamed
herself two punches if I didn't go down
there and find myself it wouldn't have
happened I wouldn't I put my family
through that Tammy's attacker has not
been found
she says the police investigation led
nowhere and the hotel has not taken any
responsibility for what happened I
really hate the way they handled
everything should these companies be
more accountable we sort of vote with
our dollars will we stay at that hotel
will we use one car service or another I
think you're totally right about us
voting with our dollar and holding these
companies very much so accountable if
these things keep happening traveling as
women how do we fix this I think we fix
this by yeah sharing our stories
speaking out so a lot of other women can
feel a lot safer
majestic elegance Resort has four and a
half stars on TripAdvisor and is sold
out for this weekend we reached out to
the resort but have not heard back and
the Dominican National Police told us in
a statement they detained ten people as
part of the investigation into Tammy
Laurence Daly's attack but they were
unable to make a positive identification
and uber told us that reports like Jen's
are upsetting and have no place on the
uber app or anywhere the problem is
again reporting it Jen didn't report
hers and it's that that shame that a lot
of these women say they feel because
they should have done something
differently even though it's not their
fault first Thank You Tammy Laurence
Daly for speaking up number
and I'm so glad that she's gonna be
alright because you look at those
pictures and it is very doubtful but
what can women do though to protect
themselves it's because I do think you
have a false sense of security when
you're on vacation especially you're
staying at a really quote nice place
right you do and we talked about these
things when we did that initial story I
mean you have to remember when you go to
that front desk don't say your name out
loud give them your ID other things that
you can do is if they say your room
number out loud ask for a different room
number make sure somebody else is right
exactly if you're staying alone you can
give the illusion maybe that somebody
else is with you leave a light on the
women that I was talking with there was
sort of a difference of opinion some
asked for two keys so they think that
somebody's staying with them others want
one so they always know where it is and
then even the State Department says that
travelers read advisories and alerts
online before they go to countries they
don't know the women that I was talking
with they did a lot of international
travel they said also know the culture
don't forget that different things in
different cultures means something if
you're walking down the street as a
single woman smiling that can mean
something really if you look at somebody
directly in the eye well Dana thank you
we appreciate it it's frustrating that
women have to take these steps and stay
vigilant we don't think that the
companies are doing more yeah it's on
them too thank you very much